mais on retrouve marie-eve qui étaient
là à sa islamabad marie-eve il ya donc
ces afghans qui sont partis mais à ceux
qui n'y sont pas parvenus qu'est ce qui
leur reste comme option maintenant
pour l'instant beaucoup de désespoir il
ya des gens les américains considèrent
qu'ils avaient vidé c'est aéroports mais
au moment où les tirs de célébrations
des talibans ont retenti dans la nuit de
kaboul il y avait encore de ces afghans
qui étaient massés autour de l'aéroport
international de kaboul j'étais au
téléphone avec l'un d'entre eux qui
depuis quelques jours espérée
désespérément pouvoir entrer il a vu ses
amis des membres de sa famille partir
alors que lui est resté derrière donc
ces tirs de célébrations pour lui
c'était un peu lent le l'envolée d'un
espoir ce qui lui reste qui restent à
tous ceux qui sont de rester derrière
c'est la voûte c'est de se rendre dans
les pays qui avoisine l'afghanistan pour
tenter de la dalle est ailleurs dans ces
pays de l'otan dans ces pays du g7 qui
ont promis d'accueillir plus de réfugiés
afghans mais c'est une route qui est
incertaine la frontière du pakistan par
exemple elle est demeurée assez
hermétique aux afghans qui veulent se
réfugier ici au pakistan il ya déjà
plusieurs millions d'afghans qui sont
réfugiés en afghanistan depuis des
décennies de guerre et le pakistan
cherche à l'éviter pour pouvoir arriver
ici j'étais au téléphone au cours de la
nuit avec un autre de ses contacts qui
avait lui décidé d'emprunter la route
alors passant de kaboul vers kandar
jusqu'ici à la frontière il faut payer
des passeurs ce sont des chemins
incertains surtout pour ceux qui
prennent véritablement pour leur vie qui
se croient recherché par les talibans
les routes sont contrôlés il ya des
points de contrôle donc qu'on doit
passer des dangers et puis ensuite il
faut arriver à atteindre le service
diplomatique de tous ces pays qui
promettent encore aujourd'hui de
continuer l'accueil des afghans il ya
une proposition de la france d' emmanuel
macron de créer une zone sécuritaire
avec le nu à l'intérieur de la ville de
kaboul pour permettre de poursuivre les
évacuations par des vols commerciaux
les négociations sont en cours là dessus
aussi oui on le disait en afghanistan
même pour ceux qui vont rester
maintenant sous ce régime taliban il ya
beaucoup d'inquiétudes beaucoup
d'incertitudes aussi sur la suite
maintenant tous les yeux sont tournés
vers les talibans le pays est entre
leurs mains ils doivent maintenant
gouverner démontré qu'ils peuvent le
faire à z parler de l'immense besoins
humanitaires qui restent en afghanistan
et c'est ce que les talibans cherchent à
préserver entre autres choses en gardant
un esprit ouvert aux étrangers comment
vont sur castrés les relations
diplomatiques avec le gouvernement des
talibans qui n'est toujours pas fort
mais on attend toujours de voir le
leader suprême des talibans qui est
tantôt mort tantôt caché à kandahar les
talibans ont affirmé que maintenant que
les américains étaient partis à bitola
koons haddad devrait faire une première
apparition mais sera-t-il à la tête de
ce gouvernement il reste énormément de
questions sur la façon dont ils vont
gérer ce pays et s'ils vont remplir ses
promesses de plus d'ouverture et de
tolérance oui alors on suivra votre
couverture dans les prochains jours
merci beaucoup marie-eve
au revoir